Christina boys time yeah her name was
just in a very soon and my daughter's
name was and he just this is part four
of what happened to Annie and use six
part series from Sky News story cast I'm
Rooney doodle
[Music]
in part three we learned that our victim
shares almost the same name as the
journalist Christina Boursin someone
whose reputation has been built on
trying to expose the secrets of u.s.
national security agencies actually I
was assigned 17 years ago
to look into the TWA story I was at CBS
I was on part 4 of a nice story the CIA
and preswick begins in the US on July
the 17th 1996 when a Trans World
Airlines flight otherwise known as TWA
left John F Kennedy Airport in New York
bound for Rome talking to people they
were saying they saw something go up and
hit the plane 12 minutes after takeoff
the plane exploded killing all 230
passengers on board Christina you're one
of these journalists who was more or
less closed down in the aftermath the
CIA were accused of covering up an act
of terrorism
being controlled among those asking the
hardest questions was one Emmy
award-winning journalist Christina
Boursin FBI came after me CBS wouldn't
let me even talk to them directly I met
with the lawyers and I was out of a job
literally weeks later this pitot er
against some of the most powerful forces
in the u.s. like the Pentagon the FBI
and the CIA it was a very professional
job they didn't you know very clean job
Christina would go on to become
something of a thorn in the side of the
US intelligence community around the
time Annie died Christina
brought an acclaimed book accusing the
US government of fabricating lies to go
to war with Iraq but then in 2014 she
would find herself pitched into the
middle of a story thousands of miles
away
the Scottish Mail on Sunday 2nd of
February 2014 did the CIA kill my
daughter in bungled hate on journalists
over torture flight story when her
lifeless body was discovered on a
Scottish beach annie Boreas ins family
were told she died of suicide or drowned
in a freak accident but her devastated
mother always suspected foul play was
involved it was a fairly well
established internet rumor the man who
wrote that article was Marshall omegle
the where articles on websites that are
followed by the sort of people who are
always looking for maybe conspiracies
and you know things that can easily be
explained like we've outlined Prestwick
Airport in 2005 was a strategic site for
the CIA's war on terror and because of
Christina Boras ins almost identical
name and record of holding US
intelligence agencies to account
suggestions Annie's death had been a
case of mistaken identity appeared
anything but groundless about the
rendition flights last week it was just
a rumor that we overheard when being in
Scotland but if it was just a conspiracy
theory christina Boysen seemed herself
to have taken it seriously we need to
know what happened to Annie and we are
certain it was not suicide and no
accident this court read by an actress
and attributed to the u.s. journalists
appeared in the Scottish meal on Sunday
we find it very hard to even allow
ourselves to think that Annie's death
had anything to do with the CIA or any
Intelligence Agency it would be like
living in an action movie but some very
strange things happened it's not like
mistaken identity hasn't resulted in the
wrong person being killed by a national
intelligence agency before
in 1973 in Lillehammer Norway the
Israeli national intelligence agency
Mossad killed a Moroccan waiter after
mistaking him as the mastermind behind
the murder of 11 Israeli athletes at the
Summer Olympics in Munich to try and
find out more we emailed the u.s.
journalist Christina Boursin dear
Christina I'm a podcast producer with
Sky News I'm making tentative inquiries
into the late Swedish girl Annie Boris
on whose story we are investigating she
emailed back seeing the article in which
she was quoted was fabricated those who
cite this as fact do so at the cost of
their credibility but they are
nonetheless free to do so those who wish
to fill the vacuum with a false
narrative are also free to do so anyone
who wants to address it is free to do so
but I do not want to engage in this and
she'd no further comment to make we
emailed again in November 2019 Christina
boysson replied with the same response
she had nothing further to add for us
the coincidence was too great to ignore
so we asked the family if there was
anything unusual anything at all from
Annie's time in Scotland that served
this theory at first glance it didn't
appear so but then Annie's best friend
Maria remember Danny telling her about a
man she met in Edinburgh zoo tonight
Club in the summer of 2005 the man had
introduced himself as an ex rugby
international they'd hit it off but it
came to nothing however in November just
weeks before Annie died the man appeared
back in her life as if from nowhere when
he turned up at a nice swimming pool she
felt uneasy and there was to be one more
encounter
during the last week when we spoke on
Saturday she had met him at Rugby Club
New Zealand team was was coming to
Scotland to play and there was a
gathering at the Rugby Club at
Murrayfield wonder so she was there and
soundly he passed her and he went down
stairs and she looked down and he came
back and gave her a look but and told me
that she got scared she felt
uncomfortable and it was a really nasty
glance in his eye she felt threatened as
a woman so that was the only thing that
she was worried about Jordan lost
conversation Annie told Maria she'd been
unnerved by the encounter because she'd
learned that the man was not who he said
he was but for GU you there was
something else on her daughter's mind
she had been calling home talking to her
worried when speaking with red eyes
productions GUI explained that these
feelings of War II heightened after
Annie called home again and suggested
she was being watched one of the calls
in terms of being she was worried about
someone tracking her online right and
when she called home she did not use the
phone in her apartment
instead she called from a phone booth
rather far away from where she lived and
she also told her her brother that we
should not call on her phone since
somebody could hear and we thought at
the time she we thought well could that
have been some of the girls in the
apartment that would overhear her saying
something too for what could that be
what was Annie afraid of
did she feel she was being monitored
tracked even was this the reason for her
deleted emails was Annie trying to
escape something her family knew nothing
about then the week before she died
Annie told Maria she was coming home so
she said I have money and we are going
to go on a shopping spree we're voltage
to shop for Christmas present and I have
to have birthday present I don't
remember if it was for her dad and she
had money she was on her way home and I
said just phone me when you are yeah
when you have arrived at sconce that and
I come and fetch you yeah and I asked
her are you coming on Friday or Saturday
well we'll see about that but four days
later after heating no more details
Maria called Annie I was going home on
my lunch hour Thursday the first
December and I phoned her mobile at my
lunch time and I I think it could be 12
o'clock between 12 o'clock and in 15
minutes past 12:00 and I didn't receive
an answer but I wasn't worried because I
knew she was going to job-seeking fare
it was a bigger event and she was going
to the Swim Center to swim so I wasn't
worried I knew she was coming Annie
never kept that Thursday appointment at
the job sphere her family say this was
totally out of character and there was
something else Annie never told her
mother she was coming home to me it was
normal that she might have travelled to
Maria first because and they were
friends and they wanted to see each
other do shopping and then come home to
us for Christmas that's that's how I
thought about it by the Friday evening
concerned by these phone calls
Julia called her daughter at the time
she was visiting her friend Kat Douma at
the whisky Center
and so I called to ask ya if there was
something special happening and and so
on then she was at the whisky Center
talking with this girl and she told me I
also what's the matter your father and
your brother are worried about you and
she said this is something I have to
deal with myself she had to take care of
something you know we talked very
briefly and I said well we can talk
tomorrow or this evening and she said
well yeah you'll see about that some
after hanging up Annie said goodbye to
cat and left only she didn't return to
her apartment
Kenneth Roy the journalist from the
Scottish review who died last year and
who done a huge amount of work on Annie
story
he discovered that Annie had one more
appointment to keep that day there was a
final conversation with a friend in
Sweden sometime between 6 and 8 p.m.
that night Annie had told her she was
going to a party in Edinburgh as her own
10 o'clock
she'd seemed positive about the party
but seemed reluctant to talk about it
where was this party who was she with
what happened at it no one has come
forward with answers to these questions
was this party connected to the problem
Annie had alluded to we don't know
but what we do know is that from this
point on Annie's movements would become
more difficult to track had Annie even
returned to her apartment that night
unfortunately our building does not have
CCTV there's an artificial camera at the
entrance hall there David Haye the owner
of Linton Court there never was actually
CCTV that I'm aware of perhaps performed
before my time but then I was sort of
that would have been before Annie's time
as well
the next day Saturday December the 4th
the police believe Annie took an early
afternoon train from Edinburgh to
Glasgow in Glasgow she changed trains
for preswick we're a ryanair flight to
Gothenburg was due to leave at 6:30 p.m.
but despite it being only a matter of
hours before the flight Annie had no
ticket again her family say there was
nothing unusual about this and we took a
stand by its dr. ray we think so
stand by do go there and you buy a
ticket that's very chic she had done
that before yes yes
2:15 p.m. Annie's bank card is used to
try and withdraw money from a cash
machine in Glasgow central train station
the transaction was logged by Scottish
revue journalist Kenneth Roy first Annie
tried to withdraw a hundred pounds then
fifty both attempts fail because there
was insufficient funds in her account
but although she filled to withdraw cash
she a bit chilly kept money in her
Filofax
we are now approaching Prestwick
International Airport 3:15 p.m. one hour
later a woman matching Annie's
appearance is caught on CCTV crossing
the footbridge joining the train station
to the airport where we're walking now
[Music]
when Annie got to preswick she no idea
that the airport was then a secret CIA
staging post for the US war on terror or
did she one Scottish police insider said
they adhered Annie had been monitoring
CIA flights at the airport whether the
source of this is rumor or there's
actually something in it is unclear but
in this conversation with red eyes
productions you can hear this theory has
caused do you some distress and I
sometimes wonder if she got to see or
hear something that she did not he
should not know about she just was in
the way of something you know in the
wrong place at the wrong time yeah
somebody would think that this girl
might talk when she goes back home or
something we need to explain what
exactly was going on at the airport in
2005 well what we know is that preswick
airport served as a key hub in the u.s.
CIA rendition and torture program
Casey Taylor is the deputy director with
reprieve a human rights organization
which helped expose CIA activities at
Prestwick rendition is the sort of means
that the CIA devised to capture torture
interrogate and detained those that they
suspected were involved in terrorism and
most of the men who went into the
process then ended up in Guantanamo Bay
and we know that through that period
preswick airport served
as a staging post really without which
rendition and torture flights would not
have been able to take place it was a
key refuelling stop in 2005 when some of
Europe's best-known airlines were flying
in and out of the airport commercial
airliners traveling from countries like
Jordan in the Middle East also joined
the queue to land they look the same as
every other passenger plane only nobody
got off these flights the CIA in
arranging rendition flights would
provide false information to airports
they would provide sort of dummy
itineraries for planes and they would
lie about what these plates were using
for and even who was on board
there was a case that was just revealed
to a parliamentary committee where the
Scottish police were suspicious of a
particular American flight at Prestwick
and were prevented from boarding and
inspecting that flight it's quite clear
that the CIA wanted this entire program
to remain secret and wanted it to remain
secret forever considering all that was
going on in the airport and the fact
Christina Boursin was in the business of
exposing US government secrets the idea
that Annie had become embroiled in some
situation involving the CIA now sounded
possible but back to Prestwick Airport
in 2005 Annie has crossed the footbridge
and is captured by the second CCTV
camera entering the terminal
it's 3:16 p.m. this is these images that
the family say they have been unable to
match up but instead of buying a ticket
Annie bypasses all the check-in desks
and exits to the car park and with
sometimes that she came out here into
this carpark here at the airport to try
and get money out of a machine but there
was also a ticket machine out here as
we're looking for the train station
3:19 p.m. three minutes later she
returns
gulia recounts the CCTV footage and when
she comes back her one of her hands is
almost in her pocket and she's got a
very angry expression in her face and
something happened a phone call somebody
not turning up whatever we don't know
what happened next
no one can make sense of Hasani again
walks straight past the check-in desks
out of the airport the way she has just
come a nice decision appears to have
been sparked by her visit to the carpark
scottish review journalist kenneth roy
speculated about what might have
happened had Annie arranged a rendezvous
in the airport with someone someone
who'd just come off a plane or was about
to board one someone who lived locally
someone she shared a brief encounter
with when she heard about this Guha
asked for whatever a CCTV footage there
was from the carpark but she would tell
red eyes productions that she was
shocked when the authorities taught her
did nothing of Annie from the carpark
people getting killed for various
reasons that that's something that
belongs on on in the movie so in a crime
story but now we live it it feels
sometimes like I'm living in one the
police say the last time Annie was seen
on CCTV was nearly 45 minutes later on a
camera in Prestwick town half a mile
from the beach
but if she was walking into a trap set
by the CIA then Annie's mother goo you
and best friend Maria see no evidence
has emerged to back it up despite these
remarkable links we have been in contact
with them Christina Baez on and she told
us that she had hadn't been to Scotland
in that period she only wrote a very
damning article about CIA planes but we
have no idea if it's related to Annie
we we have never found and we have tried
at a time when we got to know about
these we have tried to find evidence
that she was there but we haven't found
anything you know hard and cold Michelle
amigo
remains certain Annie was murdered
because once the crown office said they
wouldn't release the autopsy photos of
Annie as it wasn't in the public
interest one image does exist taken by
gulia of her daughter five weeks after
she died and having been shown this
photo by the family marchello believes
it holds the answer to Annie's death the
major thing was the massive bruising and
swelling to our temple and which made me
think immediately that she had been had
very hard on the side of the head with a
blunt instrument baseball bar or similar
and possibly with a view to robbing but
it absolutely convinced me that Annie
was modeled
but I think I think I believed that
before I saw the pictures I certainly
believed that on seeing them and I still
believe that note
inez unusual behavior in the weeks
before her death deleting emails
protecting the privacy of her phone
calls
has convinced Annie's mother goo you
that her daughter had been spooked by
something or someone maybe it was just a
gentle jealous boyfriend who killed her
I have no idea you know yes these other
elements exist so they are worth
investigating as well as everything else
should it have been the man she'd met in
Edinburgh Smoot nightclub who killed
Annie what other explanation could there
be
all these strange things we should say
at this point if you remember meeting
Annie Boursin at a party in Edinburgh on
Friday December the 2nd 2005 the night
before she traveled to preswick if you
notice anything unusual about her
behavior that night then please email us
story cast at Sky dot UK
you
[Music]